it's official print Aryan Megan Marco
are expecting their first yeah but not
even a baby on board is gonna slow down
Megan she is deep in her royal duties
yeah no listen to this make it schedule
is to attend 76 engagements in the next
16 days how many weeks we tired just
thinking about it so how is the
mom-to-be going to get enough rest Megan
was beaming when she landed in Sydney
despite a 22-hour flight and those
purple binders well they caused a lot of
reporters to wonder if the 37 year old
was hiding a baby bump ten hours later
Kensington Palace confirmed it tweeting
the Dutchess of Sussex is expecting a
baby in the spring of 2019 a palace
spokesperson tells et that Megan has
passed her 12-week mark of pregnancy and
is in good health if Alice also released
a statement from Megan's mom Maria
Ragland that she quote looks forward to
welcoming her first grandchild my
sources in LA say that Darya has found a
property over here in the UK it's close
to Kensington Palace and she is going to
be spending possibly as long as half the
year over here in the UK the Royal
timing of today's baby news is pretty
interesting Carrie Megan waited until
after the wedding of Harry's cousin on
Friday and they can fueled baby bump
speculation there she wore this
loose-fitting Jean chic coat to the
nuptials and she never took it off even
indoors the royal couple is beginning a
tour of Australia and New Zealand
they're also expected to visit Tonga and
Fiji two countries where pregnant women
have been advised not to visit because
of the Zika virus
every precaution will be in place so
that Megan and of course her uncle baby
are both safe in fact the biggest
concern is how will make him get enough
rest
the couple has 76 engagements on their
16 day tour quite a lot of pressure on
Megan and as she needs a break she'll
take a break
[Music]
[Applause]